[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
in europa droht wieder ein krieg und das
risiko ist alles andere als gebannt
guten abend zum heute-journal der
kanzler warnt zu seinem auftritt heute
bei der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
kommen wir gleich noch ausführlich
blicken aber zuerst in die ukraine nicht
nur dort rechnet man inzwischen damit
dass putin seine drohungen tatsächlich
wahr macht russische streitkräfte haben
fast die gesamte grenze zur ukraine
umgestellt wie gefährlich ist in der
region inzwischen ist zeigt christian
senn gleich zu beginn seines berichts
wie schnell sich die lage an der
frontlinie ändern kann müssen heute der
ukrainische innenminister journalisten
und parlamentarier erfahren
plötzlich granatbeschuss ganz in der
nähe die gruppe flüchtet sich in einen
nahegelegenen bunkers bange minuten
und alle wissen das hätte auch anders
ausgehen können
wir haben live gesehen wir gegen die
minsker vereinbarungen verstoßen wird
wie verbotene kaliber verwendet werden
unser beobachtungsposten war weit
entfernt von dort wo menschen leben
daher war es nicht notwendig diesen
außenposten zu beschießen gott sei dank
sind alle am leben
fast acht jahre dauert der krieg hier
schon und 2000 verstöße gegen die
waffenruhe alleine heute zwei
ukrainische soldaten starben die
prorussischen separatisten werfen der
ukraine vor das von ihnen besetzte
gebiet angreifen zu wollen die
ukrainische regierung weist das
entschieden zurück auch die usa sprechen
von einer inszenierung
die gefahr eines angriffs seien
angeblich so groß dass die separatisten
rund 700.000 zivilisten mit bussen nach
russland schicken um sie in sicherheit
zu bringen dort laufen die
vorbereitungen in notunterkünften
wir sind das denn jetzt wir haben uns
entschieden für vier tage weg zu gehen
und dann sehen wir wie es weitergeht
währenddessen rufen die separatisten zum
kampf auf
ich rufe alle männer in der republik auf
die in der lage sind eine waffe in die
hand zu nehmen aufzustehen um ihre
familien ihre kinder ehefrauen und
mütter zu schützen männer zwischen 18
und 55 sollen sich bereit machen für den
krieg
hier sind es leid zu warten es ist zeit
das zu beenden
und während die lage an der frontlinie
zu eskalieren droht startet russlands
präsident putin seine raketen show
vom kreml aus beobachtet von putin
persönlich und dem belarussischen
diktator lukaschenko
ein neues militärmanöver mit
atomwaffenfähigen raketen und
hyperschall marschflugkörpern eine
provokation die nicht nur in der ukraine
neue kriegs ängste schürt
das auswärtige amt hat jedenfalls alle
deutschen die sich in der ukraine auf
halten aufgefordert das land
unverzüglich zu verlassen ausländische
botschaften in kiew haben bereits
evakuierungspläne ausgearbeitet die
große frage in diesem konflikt wird sein
wie weit reicht die solidarität des
westens diese frage stellte heute auch
der ukrainische präsident bei seinem
auftritt auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
von dort berichtet anne gellinek
waldemar sie lenski ist nach münchen
gekommen allen warnungen von einem
drohenden russischen einmarsch zum trotz
der ukrainische präsident versuchte
gelassenheit auszustrahlen und kann der
situation doch nicht entkommen als ein
übersetzungs gerät streikt vermutet er
eine
die russen sind nicht gekommen aber sie
sind trotzdem da was dann folgt ist das
gegenteil von gelassenheit eine rede die
den westen anklagt dafür dass er die
ukraine nur halbherzig unterstützt und
immer noch versuche mit russland
auszukommen beispiel nato beitritt
selbst so friedmann erklärt uns immer
dass die türen der nato offenstünden
aber wenn einige mitglieder der allianz
uns nicht dabei haben wollen dann sagt
das doch ehrlich wir brauchen keine
offenen türen sondern klare antworten
einer der die tür zur nato lieber zu
lesen ist bundeskanzler olaf scholz auch
heute wiederholt er dass eine
mitgliedschaft der ukraine nicht
realistisch sei dass russland eine krise
vom zaun breche obwohl ein nato beitritt
der ukraine gar nicht anstehe scholz
warnt aber auch den russischen
präsidenten putin hat sich ja als
historiker betätigt und texte
geschrieben der frieden in europa kann
nur gewahrt werden wenn die grenzen und
wird nicht mehr verschoben werden wenn
sie akzeptiert werden hinter den
kulissen versucht der westen die ukraine
mit trost treffen zu beruhigen der
ukrainische aussenminister wird von
europäern und amerikanern umgarnt und
alle bestärkten die ukraine darin sich
bitte nicht von russland provozieren zu
lassen die geheimdienstinformationen der
usa über einen bevorstehenden einmarsch
machen auch die entspanntesten europäer
nervös das playbook es gibt ein drehbuch
für russische invasion dass wir nur zu
gut kennen
russland wird unwissenheit und unschuld
vortäuschen und dann unter einem vorwand
einmarschieren
hunderte expertinnen
sicherheitspolitiker transatlantiker
russland kenner sie alle rätseln wie das
drehbuch das nur putin kent weiter geht
von einem klaren bild ist die münchner
konferenz auch am ende des zweiten tages
weit entfernt
und von der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz zugeschaltet ist
uns die
bundesverteidigungsministerium guten
abend vollem recht
guten abend aus münchen die nato hat ja
gestern die einsatzbereitschaft ihrer
schnellen eingreiftruppe erhöht das
betrifft auch tausende deutsche soldaten
was steckt dahinter was befürchten sie
denn die ukraine ist ein noch nicht ein
bündnisfall wenn russland angreifen
würde
wir sind gut beraten vorbereitet zu sein
vorbereitet auf alles das was in den
nächsten tagen geschehen kann denn wir
sehen natürlich dass an der grenze zur
ukraine
die truppen aufgezogen sind alle
vorbereitungen seitens russland erfolgt
sind um angreifen zu können und wir sind
in der verpflichtung auch alles möglich
zu machen um unsere verbündeten unserer
alliierten eben auch zu schützen
deswegen ist es die richtige
entscheidung darauf zu setzen
vorbereitet zu sein das heißt man hält
es für möglich dass russland auch ein
nato-mitglied wie zum beispiel bekommen
oder polen oder ähnliches auch angreifen
würde
die bedrohung ist sehr groß in dieser
region und natürlich gehen wir erst
davon aus dass jetzt dass dieser
konflikt auch im dialog format noch
beigelegt werden kann aber wir können
natürlich nicht ausschließen dass
russland angreift und dann müssen wir
vorbereitet sein und unsere verbündeten
haben ein anrecht dann auch darauf
entsprechend gesichert zu sein dass wir
zusammenstehen das haben wir deutschen
auch dadurch unterstützt dass wir unsere
truppe in littau und verstärkt haben das
ist ein ganz wichtiges signal dass wir
hier gut vorbereitet sind in richtung
russland das muss klar sein die nato
steht hier wir stehen zusammen
geschlossen zusammen und russland muss
sich darauf vorbereiten dass wir eben
unsere verbündeten schützen die ukraine
ist ja nicht nato-mitglied insofern
nicht verbündete hat aber händeringend
um hilfe gebeten aus deutschland gab es
ja bislang nur das versprechen von 5.000
helmen was man selbst in der ukraine zum
teil für spott gesorgt hat sind dann
diese 5000 helme inzwischen endlich
verschickt
also erstmal hat ukraine ausdrücklich um
helme gebeten dieses anschreiben ist bei
uns eingegangen und selbstverständlich
prüfen wir dann eine solche anfrage ob
es möglich macht das haben wir auch
gemacht beispielsweise bei impfstoffen
während der pandemie solche anfragen
werden immer überprüft und dann wenn
möglich auch erfüllt aber
selbstverständlich ist es nicht die
einzige unterstützung die wir als
deutschland liefern wir unterstützen die
ukraine seit 2014 kontinuierlich wir
sind das größte geberland mit 18
milliarden euro die wir da schon
geleistet haben und auch jetzt in dieser
woche hat kanzler scholz gerade wieder
150 millionen euro zugelegt das ist
unser teil wwe und wie wir die ukraine
unterstützen es wird momentan
verschiedene
unterstützungsleistungen erbracht aber
verlangen dass sie ja nach dem hellen
sich ärgert das ist ja das wichtig
die helme stehen zur verfügung wir
warten darauf dass wir das signal
bekommen wohin aber nochmal das ist zum
einen eine anforderung der ukraine
gewesen die wir selbstverständlich wenn
möglich dann auch erfüllt haben aber
darüber hinaus weitreichende leistungen
die wir als deutschland erbringen die
ukraine hätte auch gerne schutzwesten
gehabt hunderttausend sowie auch von
100.000 helbig von 5.000 die rede war
diese schutzwesten sich das richtig kann
die bundeswehr aber gar nicht liefern
weil unsere eigenen soldaten nicht genug
davon haben
es war nie von 100.000 helmen die rede
sondern die anfrage der ukraine war eben
ohne eine angabe von zahlen und deswegen
haben wir das möglich gemacht was
aktuell geht und genau so war es jetzt
auch bei den schutz westen wir haben
nicht diese vorräte wie manchmal die
vorstellung ist dass wir auf
hunderttausende westen oder andere
ausrüstungs materialien zurückgreifen
können und deswegen leisten wir
unterstützung beispielsweise durch die
durch die
wirtschaftliche unterstützung 150
millionen euro wieder in dieser woche
zugesagt das sind deutliche signale an
die ukraine aber sie waren ja selbst
also die bundesregierung ist ja aus
rücksichtsnahme auf positionen innerhalb
der spd und schon bereit dass estland
neuen alter haubitzen aus ddr beständen
an die ukraine liefern kann während bei
den 100.000 150.000 quasi vor der tür
stehen
wir haben in der bundesregierung schon
sehr lange nicht erst in dieser
bundesregierung sehr restriktive
vorschriften in bezug auf
rüstungsexporte nicht erst jetzt sondern
auch schon in anderen regierungen und
daran da fühlen wir uns verpflichtet
und deswegen gibt es auch die klare
regeln dass immer dann wenn waffen
weitergegeben werden wie bei den
haubitzen dass wir dann auch wissen
wohin und darauf eben auch einfluss
nehmen können das ist ein wichtiger
grundsatz dass wir restriktiv bei der
rüstungsexportpolitik sind das heißt
aber nicht dass wir die ukraine
unterstützen ich habe schon angeführt
durch weitreichende finanzielle
unterstützung mittlerweile insgesamt
zwei milliarden euro finanzielle
unterstützung bräuchte ihre bundeswehr
möglicherweise auch jedenfalls mehr als
im haushalt eingestellt dass es war
interessant das ja scholz heute sagte
wir brauchen eine armee mit flugzeugen
die fliegen schiffe die in see stechen
können und soldatinnen und soldaten die
optimal ausgerüstet sind das ist also
derzeit nicht der fall
da hat er völlig recht und ich habe mich
sehr über diese unterstützung gefreut
nicht erst jetzt sondern das hatte auch
schon bei anderer gelegenheit zum
ausdruck gebracht denn wenn wir unserer
verpflichtung nachkommen wollen und wir
wollen dass sowohl in der nato als auch
in bezug auf die landesverteidigung dann
müssen wir ausreichend ausgerüstet sein
das sind wir zurzeit nicht wir können in
den einsätzen immer sicherstellen dass
die soldatinnen und soldaten die
entsprechende ausrüstung haben aber wir
müssen gut aufgestellt seien gerade dann
wenn neue herausforderungen an uns
herangetragen werden und wenn wir jetzt
gerade aktuell unsere truppe in littau
und verstärkt haben mit
367 soldatin der soldaten dann bedeutet
das auch dass ausrüstung damit
hingegangen ist beispielsweise
artillerie- und
solche anforderungen kommen sie auch
schnell erfüllt werden müssen dann
brauche ich auch die entsprechenden
ressourcen um dem nachzukommen und das
wird selbstverständlich gegenstand sein
der anstehenden haushaltsberatungen dann
wollen wir sehen ob herr scholz als
kanzler großzügiger ist als als er das
als finanzminister war frau ministerin
danken für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen schön groß was münchen
das interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
und jetzt gibt's andere nachrichten des
tages von hans wolff der sturm sein app
hat in teilen europas schwere
verwüstungen angerichtet mindestens 16
menschen sind ums leben gekommen drei
davon in deutschland hier war vor allem
die nordhälfte des landes betroffen ein
überblick über die lage von kamran
safari
erst am morgen wird sichtbar was der
sturm angerichtet hat auf der
nordseeinsel wangerooge ist fast 90
prozent des badestrandes weggespült mit
mehr als 160 kilometern pro stunde
trifft orkan xenapp auf deutschlands
norden in hamburg kommt es zu einer sehr
schweren sturmflut die feuerwehr rettet
menschen aus überfluteten autos doch das
wasser habe schon gesehen ich dachte ich
habe mir 14 etwas tieferen als ich
gemerkt habe wie tief diese worte
spricht weniger glimpflich verläuft es
im nordrhein-westfälischen altenberge
hier stirbt ein 56-jähriger als ein auto
von einem baum getroffen wird
glück im unglück hat dieser lkw fahrer
in bremen er bleibt unverletzt als ein
baukran in ein bürohaus kraft und ihn
dabei erwischt bis mindestens montag
nachmittag kommt es im norden
deutschlands in nordrhein westfalen zu
verspätungen und zugausfällen so die
bahn von reisen in den norden rät sie
für morgen ab weiterhin jetzt noch mal
die kulanzregelung fahrkarten für dieses
wochenende oder auch für den montag
gelten noch eine woche lang ganz
flexibel in allen zügen des fernverkehrs
noch gibt es keine entwarnung schon in
der nacht zum montag soll es wieder
stürmen erst ab dienstag soll sich das
wetter beruhigen
für weite teile deutschlands hat der
deutsche wetterdienst weitere warnungen
vor wind und sturmböen herausgegeben und
für teile von sachsen anhalt oberhalb
von 1000 metern gilt aktuell eine
unwetterwarnung vor orkanböen
zwei jahre nach dem rassistischen
anschlag in hanau ist dort an die opfer
erinnert worden zur zentralen
gedenkstunde kamen angehörige der opfer
auf den hauptfriedhof ebenso wie
bundesinnenministerium fehse und hessens
ministerpräsident bouffier am 19 februar
2020 hatte ein 43-jähriger deutscher
neuen menschen ermordet anschließend
tötete er seine mutter und sich selbst
zur krone lage da sinkt die sieben tage
incidents weiter nach angaben des robert
koch instituts liegt sie jetzt bei 1300
50,4 die gesundheitsämter meldeten dem
rk ii binnen eines tages
189.000 105 neuinfektionen 20 1684
weniger als vor einer woche 210
todesfälle kamen innerhalb von 24
stunden hinzu
nach dem ausbruch eines feuers auf einer
autofähre verkauft werden noch immer
zwölf menschen vermisst da es weiterhin
brands sind rettungsaktionen nur
eingeschränkt möglich bei den vermissten
handelte es sich um fahrer die die nacht
in ihren lkw auf dem parkdeck verbracht
hatten 280 menschen konnten in
sicherheit gebracht werden
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
23 10
24 27 45 superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
und auch die wetteraussichten für morgen
am alpenrand trocken und etwas sonne
sonst meist stark bewölkt und verbreitet
regen im nordwesten länger anhaltend und
ergiebig
starker südwestwind mit sturmböen
höchstwerte sechs bis zwölf grad und
auch montag bei fünf bis zehn grad noch
stürmisch dazu viele kräftige schauer
oberhalb von etwa 400 metern schnee
danach allmählich werte beruhigung am
mittwoch oft sonnig bei 6 bis 13 grad
das was man uns weiter geht es mit dem
aktuellen sportstudio und dann auch so
gegen 0.30 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express worden auch wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]